ظل يوسف طريح الفراش منذ ان عبرت اسرته
الحدود السودانيه صوب جنوب السودان فقد
اصيب بجروح بليغه وليست بيد والدته حيله
سوى انتظار الفرق الانسانيه لاسعاف ابنها
وكحال من فر من اثار الحرب في العاصمه
السودانيه لجات مئات الاسر الى ولايه بحر
الغزال هربا من الحرب بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع خاصه في اقليم دارفور
اجتمعت تلك العائلات في العراء وفي ظروف
انسانيه قاسيه عندنا ناس عيانين اسعافات
ده من اسرقه
في خضم هذه المعاناه تعمل الجهات الرسميه
والمنظمات الانسانيه على تقديم العون
الانساني للاجئين وتجهيز البيئه المناسبه
لاستضافه سبعه الاف لاجئ بالتنسيق مع
المجتمعات المستضيفه الناس الموجودين
المسجلين في دفاتر من من من اللاجئين في
نقطه واحده بتاعت ك
الولادات متزايد يوميا
في السودان الوضع هيكون اسوا مع تزايد
اعداد الفارينه من الحرب في السودان صوب
جنوب السودان تقول السلطات انها فتحت
معابر عده لاستقبال اللاجئين السودانيين
والعائدين الى جنوب السودان ضمن حزمه من
السياسات التي تهدف الى اعاده التوطين
وفتح المخيمات للاجئين
ورغما انحصار دائره الحرب في السودان الا
ان موجه اللجوء في تزايد مستمر وتشير
توقعات الامم المتحده الى ان نحو 800 الف
شخص سيلجاون الى الدول المجاوره بما في
ذلك جنوب السودان التي استقبلت حتى الان
ما لا يقل عن اربعين الف لاجئ